this is the view from our balcony in the
h10 a tiki palace hotel stuck in
quarantine
Liz Davis's frustration is growing by
the day and there's still confusion
about when she'll leave nothing that we
can do I'm just going to keep my
children entertained and myself
entertained and to go through the
situation some people including around
50 Britons are being allowed to leave
they arrived after the guests with
coronavirus had been taken to hospital
hvala
a la da da la da even they'd never had
close or direct contacts with the people
who tested positive that's why once
everyone including these 130 people had
been screened they could be released and
lead a normal life
you can see they didn't Norrbotten the
Foreign Office is working to establish
exactly how and when people can leave a
spokesperson said we are urgently
seeking clarification from the Canary
Island authorities following their
announcement that a hundred and thirty
tourists of different nationalities will
be granted permission to leave the Costa
a day hey Palace Hotel those left in
appearing out with a new UK case of the
virus linked to Tenerife fear is growing
among guests we spoke to one British
tourist here who told us they feel
anxious and no longer safe inside but
they've been told it could be at least
another week before they're allowed to
go home meanwhile public health England
have sent a specialist to the island to
work with the Spanish and assess how the
virus spread within the hotel as some
prepare to leave many Britons will
remain in lockdown their hopes of a
flight home still seem a long way off
Laura Bundick Sky News in Tenerife